I've been doing this thing where I wear
like little Teensy ribbony bows and I
almost threw one in today and then I was
like no I'm going to happen down I'm
gonna be cool today and then you're
wearing a ball in there now you took out
the wrong side I love it you brought
bows back thank you you know what it was
very funny we said to uh one of our
producers what we said to Jeremy that
you know JoJo's coming in and maybe we
should go get some bows yeah you know
and he bought three new sets of uh uh
headsets oh he bought the most headset
he didn't understand but we have amazing
headsets now and these are just
something my daughter brought in I love
it you sell these right this is a big uh
massive yeah massive I uh I started
selling them when I was
my gosh I was 13 so they've been in
stores now for like seven years
um
and the success of it really is it's
kind of crazy because we started selling
JoJo bows on my own just me and my team
and the success of the JoJo bow is what
Drew Nickelodeon into my life they saw
that success and they were like well we
want to be a part of this and make this
an even bigger merchandise Empire
and then there was a lot more that went
into it than just that conversation uh
and then I found Nickelodeon and we made
every product Under the Sun literally
that you could imagine and here we are
seven years later and it's just without
telling me how much you make what were
the sales of bows and maybe she will
tell you how much she makes I wish I
knew how much I made um no I don't know
how much you make I
I the bows have sold over 80 million 80
million in both how much of this but I'd
imagine how much did this cost I don't
know roughly you just bought them
they're like anywhere from like five
dollars a bow to like 14 a bow I bought
a pack
80 million dollars in bows
[Music]